Welcome students
to the Pharmacology
of Antibiotics. In
this lecture we will
describe the
protein synthesis
inhibitors. This is
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
Here are the
learning objectives.
On the right hand
side I'm trying
to help you
understand what these
learning objectives
are eliciting.
Mechanisms,
mechanisms, mechanisms.
I suggest you
chunk concepts
together because
it's a lot
easier to remember
a few things
that include
related ideas than
a bunch of
individual details.
And I invite you to
apply your knowledge,
preparation
materials and links,
and key points. This
is the same slide as
in the aminoglycosides
lecture. I have a
picture in the upper
right-hand corner of a
ribosome, bacterial
ribosome, with the protein
synthesis machinery
indicated in colors
and here are key points
that you're going
to need you can use
this as a summary you
can use it as an overview
you can use it to
help you in your
review any any way you
like to use it it's up
to you as you can see
there are numerous
drugs in this protein
synthesis group, protein
synthesis inhibitor
group, and here we
have a little mind map
of the groups. We have
our broad spectrum,
chloramphenicol and the
tetracycline, the
moderate spectrum,
just the macrolides,
the other
group is ketolides
have been
discontinued, and
the narrow spectrum,
lincosamides
and linezolid.
This is a newer group.
I'm not going to
be giving you the
pharmacology on
that because I doubt
that it will be
on the boards. You
might see it in
clinical practice and
you'll be able to
pick it up easily.
this is a little scheme
a little pictorial
to help you visualize
the different
mechanisms I'll go into
them in more detail this
might be something
that helps you in your
review and you can
draw it out maybe copy
the drawings and see
how the drugs work
antibiotic resistance
mechanisms we have
gone over before that
the concepts are the
same you can apply them
to the protein synthesis
inhibitors as you did
for other antibiotics
intrinsic resistance
microorganism just
will not be responsive
to a drug no matter
what and acquired
resistance in which an
organism was initially
responsive but then
has acquired various
mechanisms that allow
it to survive in the
presence of the drug.
Frequent or long-term
use of a particular
drug increases the
risk of microbial
mutations that produce
resistance. It is up
to all of us, on a
patient-to-patient basis,
to combat resistance
by following
stewardship guidelines
and educating patients,
encouraging patients
through knowledge
to help us out with
combating resistance.
we'll begin with the
tetracyclines this is
an old group it's in
fact the third group
of antibiotics to have
been commercialized
in the 20th century
sulfanilamide was
first and then came
penicillin and then the
tetracyclines erythromycin
followed maybe
five years later in
1952, and then the
cephalosporins about
10 or 12 years later.
I put STARS on the
important drugs to know.
Well, they're all
important to know
eventually, but for now,
this is all you need
to know. They are
likely to be tested
on the boards. You're
likely to see them
in clinical practice,
And they demonstrate
the concepts of
the tetracyclines.
Class pharmacokinetic
properties.
A few things I want
to point out is the
bioavailability of
tetracycline is good.
Doxycycline and
minocycline, about 100%.
minocycline are
not, sorry,
tetracycline are
not metabolized.
The others are.
Toxycycline is excreted
in feces, not urine.
No renal adjustment
and dosing is needed.
The half-lives
vary, actually,
according to the drug.
Tigacycline's
got a long half
-life. This is in
IV only, and it's
for serious
infections only.
Protein binding,
pretty high,
widely distributed
in body fluids.
That's what we
would expect.
Deposits in growing
bones and tooth enamel.
Hence, tetracyclines
have traditionally been
contraindicated in the
pregnant individual
and young children.
Children less than eight
years old. This will
be on the boards or
potentially be on the
boards. I don't know if
it would be on your
exam, but it could be.
Now, I've put a circle
around this part.
Doxycycline has
a relatively
low affinity for calcium.
The American College
of Pediatrics now
recommends that
doxycycline can be used
in young children and
pregnant people if
it is for 21 days or
less. And doxycycline
is usually less.
It's 7, 10, 14 days.
Tetracyclines that
remain in the gut
lumen, like
tetracycline, which
has 25%, could stay
in the gut lumen,
will modify the
intestinal flora.
And that said,
all antibiotics
actually can do that.
Getting back
to the calcium
issue, chelation
in the GI tract by
the dye and
trivalent cations
will prevent the
drug from being
absorbed, reduce the
bioavailability,
reduce the efficacy.
Antacids, mineral
supplements given at the
same time, so they have
to be separated. it.
These drugs can cause
nausea, vomiting,
so taking them with
food would be nice,
wouldn't it? That can
help, but you can't
take tetracycline, the
original dameclacycline,
or this newer one,
with food. But
you can doxycycline,
menocycline, and this
newer one. They can
be taken with food
and that can ease up
the nausea problem.
Picture of teeth
stained by tetracycline
when this individual's
mother took it
during pregnancy or
possibly the child
was given it and
so the tetracycline
chelated with the
calcium, complexed
with the calcium in
the growing permanent
teeth. And that's
what it looks like.
Mechanism of action.
Down here.
So think tetracycline,
the small ribosome,
the 30S ribosome, and
the first spot. Small
and first, tetracycline.
So tetracycline
binds to the 30S
ribosome at the acceptor
site, the A site, and
that will block the
incoming tRNA from
binding. So it doesn't bind
here, and if it doesn't
bind, it therefore
cannot add any amino
acids to the growing
chain, and protein
synthesis is stopped.
These are irreversible.
Sorry, reversible.
reversible
resistance we have some
important mechanisms
of resistance this is
mnemonics i made up
maybe you can think
of something better so
tech k k looks like an
e like an x stands for
efflux tet k staphylococcus
resistance to
tetracycline what are
we thinking about with
staphylococcus. We're
thinking about MRSA.
Okay, we know MRSA
is resistant to a
lot of things and
now we have TETK
making it resistant
to tetracycline.
We have TETAE, so
think about aerobic
enteric, that would
be gram negative,
efflux pump,
tetracycline,
doxycycline, minocycline,
but not the newer
ones. Now we
have something
called ribosomal
protection proteins.
So a protein is placed
on the ribosome
or the ribosome.
So the ribosome will
now not bind to the
drug. It's a ribosomal
protection protein.
So resistance occurs
through this TET
-M. I'm suggesting
M is in ribosome
and maybe that'll
help you remember.
Strep, staph,
enterococcus,
you notice gram positive,
tetracycline,
doxycycline,
menacycline, but not
the newer agents.
Intrinsic resistance,
pseudomonas, here
we go again, and
also proteus,
because they express
multi-drug resistant
efflux pumps.
You notice the MDR
multidrug resistance
these organisms
are resistant to
a number of different
antibiotics.
So what is it good
for if the common
infections are not
responsive to the
tetracyclines? Well it
would be a lot easier
to remember what
it's good for than
going down a litany of
all of the resistance.
We went through
the resistance
mechanisms, we talked
about the gram positive
and gram negative
that are resistant.
Doxycycline is the
most commonly used drug
in the group by far.
So zoonotic infections,
doxycycline,
zoonotic, doxycycline,
zoonotic. I bolded some
that you really should
know for this
course, Lyme disease,
which is caused by the
spirochete borrelia,
because Lyme's disease
is endemic in this
area of the Northeast,
and it's spreading.
Plague,
30% to 50% of
the population in
Europe in 1348
was decimated by
plague in a short
amount of time.
It's deadly, caused
by Yersinia pestis.
And FYI, five people
have died of plague
in the United States
in the 21st century.
So it hasn't gone
away. But it can
be treated with
doxycycline. The
idea is to recognize
it and treat
early, and people
will recover.
Rocky Mountain spotted
fever is caused by
this obligate
intracellular rickettsia.
It is deadly.
Doxycycline is
first line, and it's
only one of two drugs
that's effective.
Tularemia. This is
rabbit fever. It's
got a bunch of
different names as well.
And doxycycline is
one of the treatments
we saw before that
aminoglycosides
are also treatments
for tularemia.
Respiratory infections.
Community-acquired
pneumonia. rhinosinusitis.
So here are the
respiratory bugs that
we've gone over before.
Haemophilus influenzae,
Marcella catarralis,
Mycoplasma pneumoniae,
and Chlamytophilin
pneumoniae. And these
are the atypical.
So zoonotic, respiratory,
skin GI.
So think about
the organ systems.
You have to make
sure that the
organisms are
sensitive, MSSA and
MRSA, we remember
the potential
resistance there to
common infections,
cholera,
peptic ulcer disease.
Now let's talk
about the STDs,
******** transmitted
diseases.
I'm going to bring your
attention here
to ********.
******** caused
by the spirochete
treponema pallidum is
normally treated
with penicillin.
Recall that there is
a penicillin G form
called benzothine penicillin
which can be given
as one shot and it
will produce an effect
for 14 to 28 days and
that's certainly convenient
for treating ********,
one shot. Well,
look at doxycycline
now. It has to be given
twice a day for
14 to 28 days.
And what is the
chances of a
person sticking
to that therapy?
So that's why besides
penicillin being
highly active, it's
also much more likely to
be effective because
of that time frame.
And then malaria.
What else do we
want to talk about?
Chlamydia.
So all of these various
******** transmitted
diseases are caused
by chlamydia.
So it's only two.
I don't have any
of them bolded,
but you should know
trepidema causes
******** and the
chlamydia causes
various infections.
Remember, this is an
atypical. It's
a chlamydia.
Tigacycline now.
So this is for
complicated infections,
serious infections.
The big story
with tigacycline
is it's broad
spectrum and it's got
some important
contraindications.
So I'll let you
look at all of these
different therapeutic
uses. I want to draw
your attention to the
contraindications.
Do not use for
hospital-acquired
pneumonia.
Healthcare-acquired
pneumonia, like in
the nursing home,
ventilator
-associated pneumonia.
Because there's
lower efficacy, lower
cure rates, and
increased mortality.
With regard to
demeclocycline, and this
is the only takeaway
with this drug,
It's rarely, if ever,
used anymore. It
never was used
for its antibiotic
properties because
it causes something
called nephrogenic
diabetes insipidus.
Diabetes insipidus
is a water-losing
problem because the
kidneys are not reabsorbing
free water in the
collecting tubules.
It's just going out
when it should be
reabsorbed. And this
is because the kidneys
now are insensitive
to the hormone that
puts the water channels
into the collecting
tubules to reabsorb
that free water.
And it has, and
that hormone, by the
way, is called
antidiuretic hormone.
Antidiuretic
hormone. and that's
stored in the
posterior pituitary.
Therefore, demeclocycline
historically was
used for syndrome of
inappropriate anti
-diuretic hormone. But
we have selective drugs
now that are used instead
of demeclocycline.
It's all about
this nephrogenic,
meaning in the kidney,
diabetes insipidus,
which is a water-losing
problem because of
insensitivity to ADH.
Secondary infections,
naturally,
we have some things
going on in the
kidney with
increased blood urea
nitrogen, which is
called azotemia.
Interestingly, about
outdated tetracycline,
Something called
Fanconi syndrome,
which is a renal
acidosis, can occur when
outdated tetracycline
is consumed.
We should not be
taking outdated
drugs to begin
with. We think of
them as being likely
to be ineffective,
and that's
usually the case.
However,
tetracycline became
toxic when it
became outdated, and
it caused this
renal acidosis.
This is not likely to
be much of a problem
anymore since tetracycline
itself is hardly
ever used, but it's
an important idea to
remember, and the boards
are likely to test it.
We talked about bones
and teeth, chelation
of calcium. We
talked a little about
GI, the nausea,
vomiting, secondary
infection. Also, the
non-C. diff diarrhea.
Photosensitivity.
Here is a problem that
patients need to be
cautioned about because
it can cause this
sunburn-like burn that
can even be third
degree, can be severe.
And here's some rare but
serious adverse effects.
Hypersensitivity,
anything can
cause hypersensitivity
in the
sensitive
individual. well.
Drug specific.
Metacycline
can cause this
ototoxicity in the
vestibular region
and it can discolor
the skin with long
-term use. And
metacycline is frequently
used to treat acne,
which means long-term
use, and therefore
patients can develop
these patches, these
discolored patches.
Demeclocycline
we talked about,
tigocycline we
talked about.
Decreased absorption
by taking antacids
or mineral
supplements. Also bile
acid resins, which
is not minerals,
but it's a resin
that binds things.
So that's another way
to prevent absorption.
That means separating
these drugs from the
antibiotics. We talked
about warfarin and
oral contraceptives and
injury to the gut bacteria
that can cause
bleeding in the case of
warfarin and reduced
efficacy of oral
contraceptives in the case
of oral contraceptives.
And then other drugs
with similar toxicities.
Let's talk about
macrolides now.
There are three
in this group,
three important
drugs in this
group, erythromycin,
clarithromycin,
isythromycin, and
here is a big ring, a
lactone ring that
macrolides are known for.
I'll just hit the
important parts here.
They are widely
distributed. They do
accumulate in pulmonary
tissue, middle
air fluid, phagocytic
cells. This should
be pointing to the
respiratory system.
Erythromycin and
clarithromycin, high
potential for drug
interactions because
of CYP3A4 and p
-glycoprotein inhibition.
Anazithromycin, not,
does inhibit p
-glycoprotein,
but not CYP3A4,
so much lower
potential for
drug interactions.
Azithromycin has a
70-hour half-life.
Erycerol and chlorhycerol,
much shorter.
The azithromycin
will sequester
within the tissues,
which is why
it has such a
long half-life.
It can be taken once
a day, and it can be
taken for common
infections for five days
and produce a 10-day
course of blood levels.
What else?
This is what I
want to point out.
Erythromycin and
azithromycin, no dose
adjustment necessary
for renal impairment.
Those are the
high points of the
pharmacokinetics
of macrolides.
Mechanism. So imagine
in your mind the
big ribosome and right
in the middle at the
P site is the macrolide
site of action.
P site right here.
So these macrolides
have been identified
as working
according to this
following description.
They block elongation,
so they block the
transpeptidation step
by blocking the exit
tunnel. Let's pretend
this is an exit
tunnel, protein is being
synthesized, reaches
out into the cytoplasm
through this tunnel,
and this exit tunnel
gets blocked, and
that causes the
peptide bond formation
here to stop, and
protein synthesis stops.
Well, lots of
intrinsic resistance
here to the
macrolides, so
let's talk about
the acquired.
E-flux with
these MRS genes,
MRS, MEF, MEF.
I don't know
what those
letters stand for.
So, staph,
strep, streptococcus
pneumoniae, this
group A streptococcus,
strep pyogenes,
and ribosomal
modification. I want
to talk about
this for a minute.
something called the
ERM gene or the group
of genes it's a group
will express a protein
methylase and that
methylase will transfer
a methyl group to
the binding site and
therefore the drug will
not be able to bind.
This methylase can be
produced in a constitutive
fashion where it's
continuously there.
The mRNA is
continuously present
producing this methylase.
Or it can be inducible,
which means it's on
the DNA But there needs
to be a product around,
such as erythromycin,
that will cause it
to start expressing
this methylase. So
constitutive or inducible.
That's the
characteristics of the ERM
gene. And we see it
expressed by streptococcus
pneumoniae,
staphylococcus aureus,
strep pyogenes,
and there is cross
-resistance among all
the macrolides, but
that's not all. There's
cross resistance
with clindamycin and
streptogrammet B.
Streptogrammet B
is another protein
synthesis inhibitor
that I'm not going to
go into in this
lecture. It is in the
handout if you'd like
to read about it.
So, what's it called?
MLSB resistance
mechanism.
macrolide,
lynchosamide, which is
clindamycin, and
streptogrammin B.
So once the
methylase is present,
the organism
can be resistant
to that whole
group of drugs.
And clindamycin
and streptogrammin
B have the same
binding sites, so
that makes sense.
So what are we
using them for?
Well, respiratory.
Respiratory,
respiratory, respiratory,
that's really
the main thing.
There are others,
yes, but as you can
see, it's effective
against all of
these various
respiratory infections.
I also would like
you to remember
whooping cough caused
by Bartotella pertussis.
Pertussis means
coughing, cough.
I invite you to
go on the internet
and look for a video
that's going to
produce that
whooping cough sound
for you so you can
actually hear it.
It'll help you remember.
Whooping cough pertussis.
And ******** transmitted
diseases, not
so much anymore.
Chlamydia, it's an
alternative to
doxycycline.
Azithromycin used to
be recommended together
with ceftriaxone as
a one-dose deal for
the treatment of
gonorrhea. Not anymore,
because gonorrhea has
developed resistance.
So azithromycin
is no longer
recommended with
ceftriaxone. If
there is suspicion
of chlamydia,
then doxy.
Toxic can be
given together
with the ceftriaxone.
Skin-skin structure,
widespread resistance.
If it works, it
works great, but
susceptibility must
be confirmed first.
Peptic ulcer,
gastroenteritis,
relapsing fever.
big story here
is respiratory
infections and
gonorrhea. No more.
Abdominal cramps,
nausea, vomiting.
Erythromycin is the
most likely to cause
it. It acts on
something called motilin
receptors, which are
in the upper GI tract,
and they cause movement,
motilin motion,
motility, and
that can give
that nausea and vomiting.
Azithromycin and
chlorithromycin can do it
at high doses, but
at the doses they're
usually given in, they're
much more tolerable.
Another reason why
these drugs have
taken over instead
of erithromycin.
Diarrhea, it can be
just antibiotic and
cause diarrhea, or it
could be C. difficile.
So QT interval
prolongation, it can
cause the ventricular
arrhythmias that
are known as tracide
de pointe, which
is a drug-induced
cardiac problem.
Many, many, many drugs
can cause QT interval
prolongation.
Putting them together
increases the risk.
giving drugs that inhibit
the metabolism of QT
interval prolongers
can increase the risk
of trisodipant. I know
that you understand
these concepts now.
Hepatotoxicity is
potential. It's not
all that common, but
hepatitis has occurred
with azithromycin
and clarithromycin.
Hypersensitivity,
we expect
that potential
with all drugs.
And azithromycin can
be given in pregnancy.
Clarithromycin, no.
Erythromycin,
estalate, no. But
other types of
erithromycin, yes.
Drug interactions.
So anything that
acts at the same
site, so clindamycin
and erithromycin,
you're not going
to give together.
Other drugs at
prolonged QT interval,
warfarin, we
saw that because
of the damage to
the microbiome.
Pharmacokinetics, the
CYP3A4 and P
-glycoprotein.
I would like you to
remember statin, the
word statin, anything
that ends in statin.
This is, the
boards love this.
These are CYP3A4
substrates. they can
cause toxicity and
it's called muscle
toxicity so that's why
I want you to remember
those now
clindamycin mentioned
before same site can
be administered by a
lot of different routes
and it has activity
against the gram
-positive aerobes,
MRSA, community-acquired
MRSA, gram-positive
and gram-negative
anaerobes, as long as
they're susceptible and,
of course, resistance
is increasing, and
some parasites, which
I'll get to when we
talk about parasites.
This, as you may
recall from that little
mind map in the
beginning, is a narrow
-spectrum drug. So it's
easy just really to
remember gram-positive
aerobes and anaerobes
gram negative
anaerobes that's it you
can do it and virtually
three ideas talk
about resistance on
the next slide lung
abscess pelvic inflammatory
disease skin skin
structure all these
various types of gram
positive and anaerobic
type infections
that's that's the
takeaway. And abscess,
abscess, abscess,
above the waist, long
abscess, although
resistance is increasing.
I'm afraid I have to
say that after everyone.
Clindamycin has
long been associated
with C. difficile,
causing C.
difficile infection.
Of course, it's not
the only one. And
it can be severe.
Pregnancy, safe. So
now we have a couple of
drugs that we know
are safe in pregnancy.
And then drug
interactions,
basically anything that
hits it at the
same target.
But also here's something
interesting that
you won't see with
any of these others.
The clindamycin vaginal
cream is in an oily
base, and that oily
base can weaken condoms
and the diaphragms,
contraceptive diaphragms.
So individuals who
practice contraception
using either of these
devices should be
cautioned when
they receive a
prescription for
vaginal cream,
clindamycin
vaginal cream.
Resistance. Okay,
let's talk about this
again. We mentioned
that the MLSB ERM
genes are either
constitutive or inducible.
Now, we worry about
inducible with
staphylococci and
streptococcus pneumoniae,
which, as you know,
are serious, hard
-to-treat infections,
especially MRSA.
So if the IRM
gene is present,
the infection may
seem to respond
to clindamycin
in the beginning,
but there can be
therapy failure because
the resistance can
emerge during therapy.
Well, the potential
for this can
be tested by
something called AD
test. So let's see
what that is. We
have four panels here.
I draw your attention to
C. Let's begin with C.
This is an
erythromycin disc.
Here's a clindamycin
disc. They're
impregnated with
the antibiotics.
We see a zone of
no growth around
both of these
discs, which
means the drugs
are effective.
Looking at D now, here
are the discs, and
the bacteria are growing
around both of them,
showing that
the drugs, both
the drugs, are resistant.
I mean to say the isolate
is resistant
to both drugs.
On B, the organism
is growing around
the erythromycin,
but not the
clindamycin. So
clindamycin is effective,
but erythromycin
is not. Now, that
brings us to panel
A and our D zone.
So, I've drawn a line
around the D zone.
This means that the
isolate possesses
the ERM gene and that
the erythromycin has
induced it to start
producing the mRNA
which will make the
protein methylase.
we know that because
the organism is starting
to grow into the
clindamycin area so the
clindamycin area now
looks like a d because
of the staphylococcus
i guess it's
staphylococcus growing
into the clindamycin
zone so this is now
going to be reported
as resistance clindamycin
resistance the
organism is resistant
to clindamycin the
d test the reason
it's being reported as
resistant is because
of the possibility
of therapeutic failure
as the staphylococcus
or streptococcus
or the pneumococcus
start to produce
constitutive methylase,
constitutively active
ERM gene methylase.
D-test.
That brings us now
to chloramphenicol.
Chloramphenicol
binds reversibly, all
of these in this
lecture are reversible,
to the 23S RNA in
the 50S ribosome. I'm
sure that sounds familiar
by now, macrolides
and clindamycin also.
But chloramphenicol
is in a slightly
different spot. So
it has a different
mechanism of action.
It seems to interfere
with the binding
of the tRNA to
the acceptor site.
So even though the
clindamycin is in
here, it's preventing
the binding of
the tRNA with the
amino acid on it.
And that's going to
prevent an interaction
between the
peptidyl transferase
in the P-site and
the amino acid on the
tRNA in the A-site.
And that's going
to prevent the peptide
bond formation.
So chloramphenicol is
slightly different.
Chloramphenicol is highly
lipophilic, poorly
soluble in water.
It is formulated in
a salt, it's called
succinate sodium
salt, so that it can
dissolve in the
solution in the IV bag.
The pharmacokinetics
of chloramphenicol
are very important for
optimization of
therapy. That's why I'm
going through all
of this for you.
It is given only IV
in the United States.
Of course, it's got
great oral absorption,
but we don't use it
that way because of
the toxicities of
this drug. We barely
use chloramphenicol
for anything anymore.
So let's talk about those
pharmacokinetics again.
Succinate salt is
rapidly converted by
esterases in the
plasma to the active
chloramphenicol.
The chloramphenicol
is not in the
salt. it's got pretty
high protein binding
it is widely distributed
with good ***********
into the CSF remember
it is lipophilic
good *********** into
ocular tissues and it
used to be available
in the US and eye drops
good *********** into
the prostate fluids
and tissues it
undergoes glucuronide
conjugation so it's it's
metabolized in the liver
by UDP glucuronyl
transferase and two
inactive metabolites and
excreted in the urine
so active drug goes
into the urine also.
Broad spectrum,
bacteriostatic,
pia region
also again is resistant.
Drug inactivation
by acetylation of
the drug, bacterial
acetyltransferase.
So the drug itself
is inactivated.
it has been used
traditionally to treat
rocky mountain
spotted fever with a
kethial infection
which i mentioned is
deadly if left
untreated in children
less than eight years
old and pregnant
people why because
doxycycline and other
tetracyclines have
traditionally been
contraindicated
in this group.
Well now, as I mentioned,
the American Academy
of Pediatrics
allows, recommends
doxycycline to be
used, especially
for Rocky Mountain
spotted fever in young
children and pregnant
people as well as
everybody else.
It's also been used
for meningococcal
meningitis remember it
is bacteriostatic but it
does produce excellent
CSF levels it's
only used when nothing
else will work and it
would not be used alone
so adverse effects
mitochondrial toxicity
it is lipophilic
it can get into the
mitochondria and it will
inhibit mitochondrial
protein synthesis.
So it can cause
quite an array of
toxicities, bone
marrow toxicity,
Gray syndrome,
which I'll talk
about on the next
slide. This one is
called idiopathic
aplastic anemia.
Not sure exactly
the mechanism.
It doesn't occur in
very many people,
so it's likely
happening to people
who are sensitive for
an unknown reason.
It is irreversible
and deadly.
Aplastic anemia means
that the bone marrow
is not producing
any blood cells.
Plus your normal run
-of-the-mill, which
is also very serious
bone marrow toxicity.
The drug can also
cause nausea,
vomiting, diarrhea.
You would expect
these with lots
of antibiotics.
Stomatitis, which
is an inflammation
in the mucous
membranes of the mouse.
Glossitis, which is an
inflammation
of the tongue.
Optic neuritis, these
are neuropathies,
peripheral neuritis,
headache and confusion.
Pregnancy, it is a
recommended alternative
for Rocky Mountain
Spotted Fever and Plague.
But of course, we know
we can use doxycycline.
We have to be
cautious about the
third trimester
because of this gray
syndrome. And we
have a CYP2C9.
Okay, gray syndrome.
High risk in pediatric
patients, and we're
thinking really of
neonates, especially
********* and full
-term newborns, as well
as infants that are
a bit older, all who
have immature hepatic
and renal functions.
That's the key here, the
immaturity of the
functions of these
newborns. They
have immature
UGT, so they have
reduced ability to
metabolize the chloramphenicol,
so there will be
more drug in the blood
for a given dose.
They have reduced
levels of plasma
proteins, so a higher
fraction of free drug.
They have immature
kidney function, so
increased plasma
concentrations of the drug.
All of these are
pointing to the fact
that but there will
be significantly
increased levels in
the blood. So when
chloramphalicol is given
to these little tykes,
the levels need to be
carefully monitored.
The doses need
to be carefully
monitored because increased
drug concentration
increases the
risk of these
concentration
-dependent toxicities I
talked about in
the previous slide.
drug accumulation in
the neonate causes these
toxic levels gray
syndrome it's now called
used to be called
gray baby syndrome but
now it's gray syndrome
vomiting flaccid muscles
abdominal distension
hypothermia and
cyanosis and it's the
cyanosis that causes that
gray collar It can
progress to vasomotor
collapse, irregular
respirations, and death.
Onset is two to nine
days after starting
the therapy, but the
progression is rapid.
The drug has to be
removed immediately.
Now, it's now called
gray syndrome because
other people, the
newborns, but people,
especially the elderly
people, who may have
reduced kidney function,
reduced liver function,
may also be susceptible
to gray syndrome.
That takes us to
the oxazolidinones.
Lonezolid is the
prototype of this group,
still the one that's
widely used. This
has a different action
than we saw with
the other ones. It
binds again to the 23s
RNA at a point that's
near that A site.
It's in the 50S
ribosome, but it binds at
the site A site near
the 30S, and that will
prevent the formation
of that initial complex
that initiates protein
synthesis. So the
protein synthesis never
gets off the ground.
IV and oral, 100%
bioavailability, widely
distributed in all
the various tissues
including the CSF,
minimal metabolism,
inactive metabolites, non
-renal renal excretion,
five-hour half-life
in adults okay all
this sounds great
right you can do an
IV to oral switch
don't it can be exactly
the same dose it's
going to get where
it needs to go how
great is that well
let's see what the
problems are gram
positive only only
only only gram
positive only only only
bactericidal against
the streptococci but
it's bacteriostatic
against everything
else well that's okay
it can still effective
MRSA enterococcus
including VRE
tuberculosis MDR and XDR
extensive drug resistance
as if MDR is not
enough we now have
XDR and there's really
very little resistance
and no cross
resistance all of these
really favorable
features well the
resistance can occur
with point mutations at
the binding site you
could predict that.
Intrinsic resistance,
aerobic gram negative
bacteria and all
anaerobic bacteria. So
what's it useful for?
Gram positive,
aerobic gram positive
organisms. Strep,
staph, enterococcus.
step strep enterococcus
skin skin structure
nosocomial and
community acquired
pneumonia cns infections
bone joint drug
resistant tuberculosis
and more well let's
take a look at the
adverse effects
thrombocytopenia that
usually only occurs
after a longer duration
thrombocytopenia is
low platelet count
and but sometimes
the lenezolid has to
be used for a longer
period for difficult
infections oh here it
is again mitochondrial
toxicities
peripheral neuropathy
optic neuritis lactic
acidosis again with
the longer duration
of therapy even longer
than we see with the
thrombocytopenia.
So how does it work?
Sorry, the
adverse effects.
Linazolid is a weak
monoamine oxidase
inhibitor. Monoamine
oxidase is an
intracellular enzyme,
highly expressed in
many, many tissues,
including the liver
and in neurons. And
it is important for
inactivating serotonin
and norepinephrine
and also dopamine.
We're talking
about serotonin and
norepinephrine here.
By inhibiting monoamine
oxidase, that will
increase the levels
of serotonin and
norepinephrine in the
brain and periphery,
obviously, because
it's not being broken
down, and that
increase in serotonin
levels is going to
increase the risk of
serotonin syndrome
in patients taking
serotonergic drugs.
All right, what
are serotonergic
drugs? I have a
list of them here.
Serotonin reuptake
inhibitors, those are
antidepressants,
tricyclic antidepressants,
And, therefore, if
we give lonezolid,
which is an MAO
inhibitor, that can
increase the levels
of all of these drugs,
which could lead to
serotonin syndrome.
Serotonin syndrome is
often mild and
reversible.
Patient is uncomfortable,
headache maybe,
some confusions,
palpitations.
But it can be severe,
it can lead to
hyperthermia and
hypertensive crisis.
So patients, first of
all, the literature
recommends that
linezolid be avoided
in patients who are
taking these drugs,
sometimes zolanezolid
is the only
drug that can be
given, so the patient
must be carefully,
carefully monitored.
So drug disease
interactions. Uncontrolled
hypertension because
norepinephrine
increases blood
pressure and heart rate.
So uncontrolled
hypertension.
Pheochromocytoma,
which is a tumor
that increases
norepinephrine levels.
Thyrotoxicosis,
it's already causing
increased blood
pressure and heart rate.
Then, going down here
to sympathomimetic
agents and vasopressive
agents, because they
can, they do, this is
their job, increase
blood pressure and or
increase heart rate.
see how it's all
connected you see the
mechanisms there
miperidine is an opioid
analgesic and it
also has serotonin
increasing
increasing effects
now tyramine
tyramine is found
in certain foods like
aged cheese and wine
beer and pickles
and salami and other
yummy stuff Well,
tyramine is inactivated
by monoamine oxidase,
too, and if that
is inhibited, tyramine
levels can increase,
displace norepinephrine,
and lead to
increased blood
pressure and heart rate.
So linezolid has
some serious adverse
effects that must be
considered when thinking
about choosing
linezolid as a therapy,
which requires
monitoring if the
patient must get it.
Plus, you need to know
linezolid is really,
really expensive.
Okay, here are
some questions.
I I would suggest you
pause the video, but
I'm not going to go
over these questions.
The answers are at the
end of this PowerPoint.
And I really encourage
you to try and
think of the answers
before you look at
the answers. And
by all means, talk
to people in your
group. Talk to each
other. You don't have
to do this alone.
it's important to
learn together to work
together you're not
going to be working
in clinical practice
by yourself and I
have two pages of them
and a really brief
summary it's actually
a synopsis because
the summary of all
the individual drugs
is really in the
beginning under key
points I'm not going
to read this to you.
And I put the same
mind map here and
I indicated underneath
in the ideal
world if bacterial
resistance is absent
all of the different
organisms that
would be susceptible
to these drugs.
Tetracyclines is
a big list as you
can see they are
broad spectrum.
Chloramphenicol I've
just grouped them
according to what they
are aerobic gram positive
aerobic gram negative
anaerobic and atypical
that just covers
just about everybody
macrolides the we see
a lot of respiratory
organisms strep and staph
which are pretty much
resistant now the
atypicals spirochetes,
and this
mycobacterium species.
Lynchosamide
narrow spectrum,
aerobic gram
-positive, MRSA,
and anaerobic bacteria.
Easy to remember.
Streptogrammins
I put here.
I'm not testing
you on these.
It's gram-positive only.
and linezolid, which
is gram-positive only.
That's it.
And here we have
the answers to the
questions. That
concludes this lecture
on the protein
synthesis inhibitors.